they're all you know living this life
that you just can't believe that this is
a a job you can't even believe people
can make a living doing it and and this
was the time when you know teenagers
like the whole movie industry was just
geared to making movies about teenagers
you know had John Hughes and everyone
just wanted to make movie about young
people and I love that time it was a
great time and we don't remember that
like how the focus went really to the
youth during the early 80s and I mean
it's it's not really that way anymore um
no and it was real think about it I
didn't even think about that but you're
talking about John Hughes and Francis
for copel in these movies like Stand By
Me that came out also those kind of
moviesfast Club um Rob Ryan are director
Stand By Me yeah but like these movies
where it's coming of age these you know
real grounded stories with characters
and it seems like there's none of that
and it's all either
superhero or uh or
what uh I mean no I'm not saying it's
bad I'm just saying well for me I just
miss that I miss that sort of it was
nice to grow up with that and see you
know kidss my age and like oh my gosh
look what he's going through Coming of
Age like rights of Passage was they were
always a River's Edge remember like what
a great movie like all these movies we
as teenagers were watching these other
teenagers with really hard things I mean
you even had like even blue velvet like
they were young people and they were
thrust into like crazy situations and so
that time was such a good time to be in
Hollywood as a young person because
there was so many great projects always
um around you know and and so the people
you know 18
1920 if you're in Hollywood in 1982 to
you just you're it's like a feast of
Incredible movies being made and um so I
was like I want to be there I want to be
part of that so I went to I went to
college freshman you know in my dorm and
I soon was like getting you know itchy
fingers like how can I get down to LA
and luckily the casting director for
rumblefish and The Outsiders Janet
Hinson she said come on down and I'll
get you some auditions and we can see
and she helped me get an agent and this
is without like a lot of experience this
was just with my one little extra and
you had not really you hadn't done a lot
of acting I mean only High School acting
yeah in my high school place but were
you good I mean I I hope I was good she
she had faith in me that's the thing is
that she had a lot of faith and she was
really encouraging